[Musique]
sur la question des marques qui était
prête et les biens furent dès l'école
temps reste à comprendre et à dire sur
la question des tests
j'attends que précisément on dise quelle
va être la politique menée dans notre
pays sur une campagne de tests que
j'appelle comme étant généralisé sur la
question des masques quand est-ce que
nous passerons à la généralisation des
masques pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
autant de questions qui sont des
questions précises pratique et qui
peuvent nous permettre de sortir de
cette crise là après celle de la réponse
dans l'urgence à la situation que nous
avons connue
il faut maintenant une anticipation une
stratégie moi je ne comprends pas
pourquoi
avec la technologie dont sont capables
les français on n'est pas à même
aujourd'hui de conduire une campagne
massive de test on voit bien les
difficultés que ça pose dans les étals
mais est reconnu un certain nombre
d'erreurs
un certain nombre de failles de
dysfonctionnements également dans la
criée dans la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire les erreurs que nous avons
pointé depuis le début de manière
constructive
chez les républiques ce qui va manquer
maintenant c'est la stratégie pour le
déconfinement je pense que le
confinement en réalité c'est une
stratégie de pis-aller
c'est une stratégie très défensive mais
maintenant il va falloir passer vraiment
à l'offensive comme l'ont fait beaucoup
de pays asiatiques est aussi européens
dans le moment actuel on a besoin au
moins que le cap qui est donnée soit
dans la mesure des éléments dont on
dispose aussi cohérente possible
surveiller et compter les destins dans
les ehpad
c'est bien mais les prévenir ça serait
plus encore et moi j'observe une chose
qui m'irrite un peu c'est qu'au fond la
seule prévention passive qui est fait
actuellement ce sont les français qui la
font en étant confiné
parce que j'attends du directeur général
de la santé c'est qu'il décide par
exemple dans les ehpad
mais aussi dans les établissements
médico sociaux dont il a parlé dans les
prisons je pense que ça serait son
travail de mettre en oeuvre une
politique de dépistage massif de tous
les résidents et ainsi de prévenir ces
morts qu'ils comptent tous les soirs
c'est quand même intolérable
[Musique]